[Musique]
oui dépêchez vous s'il vous plaît parce
que ça va commencer là déjà je sais pas
vous mais par là bas qu'est ce que c'est
que ça là c'est le code rossouw nom mail
tricheurs je rêve mais pas du tout je
reste dans le métro non mais il n'y a
pas de ça dans la salle d'examen vous me
donnez ça s'il vous plaît un temps que
garée en double file
autour le passage à l'utiliser mais trop
long faisait faire un écran de fumée qui
vient de tuer mon coéquipier est tombé
pour chorégraphe et me suis fait flasher
à 8000 46 km heure sur l'a6 classique
excusez moi vous êtes batman correct 1
j'étais persuadé vous n'existez pas
ouais bah pareil ouais ouais demi tour
du cou
dans mon rétroviseur un vrai bon me fait
des appels de flat anrs du typhon de la
maison arc aryenne première du nom le
must de game of thrones will rain de
merine reine des sandales reine de
renard et des premiers hommes suzeraine
des sept couronnes grand public du
royaume calissi de la grand-mère
herbeuse mer des dragons l'un brûlé me
st
je voudrais savoir si je peux aller
faire un petit pot pot en fait c'est sûr
que là c'est démystifier un peu non vous
aviez qu'à faire ça avant ma petite dame
et lui c'est qu'ils lorraine oui oui et
depuis quand l examinateur d'auto école
oui oui tu as they will oui oui oui
ainsi va ce qui me semblait sous le
stress des embouteillages un passage et
à imerys de typhons de la maison un
férié à la première du nom reine des
andes à la reine de projets pas dire
tout simplement la meuf avec les dragons
noirs suzeraine des sept couronnes la
grande magie serait plus simple pour
tout le monde si c'était écoutez si vous
me couper encore une fois je recommence
depuis le début calissi de la grand'mère
herbeuse mer des dragons est l'un brûlé
[Musique]
eh ben je sais plus ce que je voulais
dire maintenant donc pardon excusez moi
ça me revient d'un coup là diaries du
typhon de la médiation sera soit parce
que vraiment un appât ses dragons à
dispo la mois la durée la fête des
champignons qu'est ce qu'il fait là d'un
il serait pas que la nuit ap oui à temps
j'ai été en train de sorts tu as le
génie de la lampe est ce que vous faites
là vous êtes en train de tricher
[Musique]
l'ama
même temps à huy a alors vous et ben 40
sur 45 telle situation vous êtes le seul
à l'avoir reste super pourra livrer tous
mes cadeaux et remplir le coeur de tous
les enfants du monde entier alors calmos
tout de suite parce que ça c'est le code
c'est l'épreuve théorique
maintenant il faut passer la pratiquer
la conduite donc ouais j'ai un créneau
en février la mi-février ça vous va
c'est impossible comment je fais moi
pour livrer mes cadeaux attendez j'ai
peut-être un mec qui pourrait vous
dépanner il a le permis et il n'aime pas
trop son staff actuel donc ça peut le
faire
ouais c'est ça je vous donne sens à 0,6
les rendez vous le 25 décembre à 21h sur
w9 pour fêter les 5 ans de gold
moustache cinq ans de rire et moi j'aime
rire et tu peux aussi nous voir sur
scène à l'olympia le 14 janvier
cliquer ici pour acheter ta place c'est
sur scène et moi j'aime la scène oh oui
j'aime ça